in 2020 one
singularity dominated the news there was
one story
that filled almost every front page of
every paper
on every day if i asked you what was the
biggest story from 2019 or 2018
or 17 or almost any other year was
there'd be some debate
but not in 2020 i don't even have to
tell you what i'm talking about
you already know but just because the
front pages were clogged up
that's not to say page 2 3 or 4 were
while we may have stood still the world
kept spinning and news kept happening
some of it was heavy some was sad some
was bizarre
and some momentous but what binds these
stories together
is that you likely didn't hear about
them by no fault of your own
it was difficult to follow what was
happening in the world because the only
thing you could hear
was that one singular story the year's
not over yet though
at least as i'm saying this and so
there's still a chance to catch up
on the news you missed in 2020 from
every country
in the world here's how this will work
we order the countries by population
from largest to smallest according to
2019's
statistics there are 195 of them
193 countries recognized by the united
nations plus two un observer states
palestine and the vatican city this list
was chosen because
it is the most definitive list it's the
list most commonly used as a list of all
countries
so some of its entries might include
nations that you or your government do
not consider as countries
or omit ones that you or your government
do recognize
at the end of the day we had to pick a
list and if any is
the list of countries it's this one oh
and one more rule
the c word as in the word that describes
that one singular story of 2020
you're not going to hear it once
we start in china the most populated
country
in the world which continues to expand
its global presence and in this case
its space presence too it became the
second country in the world to plant a
national flank on the moon
50 years after the united states did
china is trying to catch up with
american and russian planetary endeavors
and in recent years has poured millions
into its military-run space program
with the hopes of sending humans to the
moon another country with a burgeoning
space program
is india where amazon recently completed
its largest office building in the world
the 1.8 million square foot behemoth was
erected in hyderabad
a city of 10 million that's grown into a
sizeable technology and financial hub
india as the world's second most
populous country is the fastest growing
internet market and amazon joins other
major tech multinationals which have
open offices there
though none with a campus that spans 65
football fields
a united states man that was facing
sentencing for two vehicle theft charges
might be looking at a lot more time now
that he was caught faking his death
his attorney submitted a fraudulent
death certificate and it might have
passed had there not been typos like the
misspelling of registry
stay in school kids in indonesia a
stimulus bill aimed at restarting
southeast asia's largest economy was met
with
months of protests because citizens said
it slashed workers rights and
environmental regulations
but president joko widodo signed the
bill into law anyway
saying it will bring over 1 million jobs
to the struggling economy which until
this year had been
on an upward trajectory opponents though
argue it weakens rules that already
don't do enough to protect the country's
natural resources
and workers rice is a serious business
in southern asia
and it's a profitable one too that's why
pakistan is
vehemently fighting india over the long
grain basmati to be specific
this year india applied to the european
union for a designation that recognizes
basmati rice as an exclusive export of
the country
even though one-third of eu imports on
the products come from pakistan
in recent years pakistan's basmati rice
exports to the eu have
doubled while india's are shrinking
which makes the designation
if granted potentially more devastating
and further increases tensions between
these two neighbors between rainforest
fires and a negligent president
the new streaming out of brazil has been
heavy but
a new discovery about the mating habits
of the thoropatelfura frog
lightened the feed frogs are either
typically monogamous
or not meaning they get around this
species however prefers harem style
one male to two or more specific females
which is much more common
in mammals throughout the animal kingdom
but not seen before
in amphibians dubbed group fidelity
finding this behavior in another set of
four-legged animals
checks another box in the evolutionary
list
one particular virus has dominated the
news cycle this year
but in nigeria they're dealing with an
entirely different one
too the yellow fever the disease which
is spread by mosquitoes
had basically been eradicated for 20
years until 2017
when it crept back into the country
because of climate change and lower
vaccination rates
now it's spiking in the latter half of
75 people have already died and health
officials worry that number will
increase
as people are still hesitant to get
vaccinated
india is being beat in another metric as
well and
it's an important one bangladesh most
likely surpassed india in gross domestic
product
this year according to international
monetary fund estimates
why does that matter well india is the
world's sixth largest economy
and its 10 gdp contraction is a
concerning indicator for the world
economy
thanks to increased agricultural
production and a focus on developing its
low-wage labor workforce
bangladesh on the other hand was able to
expand its gdp
by four percent this year another
country that's known to be
slightly competitive is russia and
that's a problem
since they were banned from the biggest
global sporting competition of 2020
because of doping
that would be the summer olympics in
tokyo
of course the event was postponed until
2021 anyway
but new investigations reveal that
russia was planning to cyber attack the
games
which is something they've done before
when they attempted to wreak havoc on
the winter olympics in south korea
by dismantling ticketing and wi-fi for
the opening ceremony as well as
targeting individual broadcasters
sponsors
and athletes before flights were ground
to a halt in the spring
one health insurer in utah was taking
advantage of mexico's inexpensive
pharmaceutical prices
and actually flying public employees
from the united states to south of the
border so they could buy drugs at a
fraction of american prices
they also got the benefit of those
in-flight snack peanuts and a free soda
it's already saved the company a quarter
of a million dollars and now
other states are eyeing the move and may
mimic it once flight schedules resume to
normal levels
meaning mexico is bound to see an even
greater boost to its already bursting
pharmaceutical
tourism industry fugaku is not just fun
to say
it's also the name of the world's
speediest computer which was built this
year
in japan the room-sized computer took
first place in a speed ranking
competition between supercomputers
carrying out 2.8 times more calculations
than the second place ibm machine built
in the united states
this is notable for the japanese who
have remained less competitive in the
supercomputer realm
often following the leads of the us and
china
the systems are used for complex
military and scientific tasks
including breaking code and modeling
climate change and of course
winning competitions africa is getting
its own
great wall a green one the ambitious
reforestation project is supposed to
stretch
4 350 miles or 7 000 kilometers from
djibouti to senegal with an aimed
completion date of 2030.
ethiopia is on track to meet its goal
having already planted 5.5 billion
seedlings
but its neighbors are slow to start and
the project is only four percent
complete at the halfway mark
mostly due to financial struggles it
turns out
it takes a lot of green to make a green
wall and so it's proving difficult for
some of the world's poorest countries to
take this project
to completion money problems are also
the reason that the philippines largest
news network cited
when it shuttered dozens of its regional
stations around the country
but the audience isn't buying this
excuse
instead they're wondering if it has more
to do with president rodrigo duterte's
criticism of the network's coverage
of his anti-drug platform either way the
loss will be felt
by millions of rural residents who rely
on the network as a lifeline
for critical information wealthy
residents of egypt are getting their 15
minutes of fame
just 2500 years too late more than 100
ornately painted wooden coffins were
unearthed by archaeologists near shakara
20 miles or 30 kilometers south of cairo
this area is a large burial ground and
is home to more than a dozen sites with
similar tombs
this discovery however is one of the
most exciting in recent years and comes
at a time when the country continues to
try to draw tourists back
after a sharp decline resulting from the
arab spring in the early 2010s
tourism isn't a problem in vietnam where
18 million people visit per year
and that should mean liquor sales aren't
either
but a new zero-tolerance drunk driving
law that went into effect this year
has taken the fizz out of one of the
world's faster growing beer markets
since implementation beer sales have
dropped 25 percent
in the country and violators face a fine
of up to 345 dollars
which is double what the average
vietnamese makes in a month
even those who think riding a bike is a
safe alternative will be shocked with a
fine for drunk peddling in other 2020
epidemic news
the world health organization declared
that an ebola outbreak in the democratic
republic of the congo
was officially over after two years and
deaths it was the country's tenth
outbreak of the disease
but it's second most deadly stemming
from people's mistrust of the government
and feuding between officials that
doesn't mean the country is in the clear
though as it's now dealing with the
world's largest measles epidemic
and of course the global pandemic
germans are taking a stand
and well technically a sit in denman
reuter forest south of frankfurt
where they've been camped out to oppose
the government's construction of a
highway that will route through the wild
lands and cut down 67 acres
or 27 hectares of 250 year old trees
these activists are calling the
government hypocritical for cutting down
cherished trees when it should focus on
public transportation infrastructure
and both sides expect standoffs for
months to come
also bad news for trees are the more
than 9 million that have died
in turkey last year as part of national
forestation day
volunteers across the country planted 11
million trees across more than
2 000 sites including 303 150 saplings
planted in courtroom
which broke the world record for most
trees planted in a single location
now officials are reporting that up to
90 of these have died
because they either weren't planted
properly or lacked enough rainfall to
grow
in neighboring iran a woman was filmed
riding a bike without a hijab near a
major mosque in naifabad
why is this news well in iran it's been
against islamic law
since 1979 for women to be seen in
public without a covering for their head
and hair
and this is largely obeyed though women
have started to push the limits in
larger cities like tehran
it's still widely criticized and in this
case punishable
the woman was arrested for this display
which was widely shared on social media
another arrestable offense this time in
thailand is writing a bad online review
yes you heard that correctly an american
living in the southeast asian country
wasn't happy with being charged a 15
corkage fee at a beach resort in kochong
so he did what any thumb happy traveler
would do
and wrote a negative trip advisor review
the hotel was equally displeased and had
him arrested on defamation charges which
are notably harsh in a country that
attempts to stifle
some free speech he therefore spent a
weekend
in jail in more turbulent waters
construction started on what will soon
be
the world's largest offshore wind farm
when completed
the dogger wind farm in the north sea
off the eastern coast of the united
kingdom
will provide enough energy to power 4.5
million homes every year
or 5 percent of england's total energy
demand the enormous energy production
capability is made possible by their use
of one of the world's largest wind
turbines
the halyard x which stands 853 feet
or 260 meters tall and has 351 foot or
107 meter blades
requiring much less power than that
though is the ami
a mini car released in france that can
be driven without a license by anyone
over
14. manufactured by citroen the
all-electric me is what's officially
dubbed a light quadricycle
the four-wheel cube can travel 28 miles
per hour or 45 kilometers per hour
with a range of 46 miles or 75
kilometers and it's got a mini price too
ringing in at just over seven thousand
dollars
another european product is making
headlines but this time it's for the
lack of it
the world's second largest producer of
olive oil italy
has been plagued by bad weather and a
deadly bacteria cutting production by
more than a quarter
this year the xylella bacteria also
called leprosy has hit the olive trees
in the paglia region particularly hard
and those effects will be felt globally
especially in the united states
which purchases one third of italy's oil
at the southern end of the world a 116
year old man
died in south africa he was however the
oldest man in the world at the time of
his passing at least unofficially
having lived through the spanish flu
which took the lives of his entire
family
he credited his long life to quote god's
grace
but it may have been health and strength
too a couple weeks before he died of
natural causes
his family said he was chopping wood
with a four pound hammer
up the african coast the two largest
tanzanite gemstones ever on earth
were pulled out of the only country in
which they're found tanzania
the two dark violet blue minerals each
about 11 inches or 30 centimeters
long and 4 inches or 10 centimeters
thick wrang in roughly 3.35 million
dollars for the mining boss who runs the
200 person operation in the country's
northern region
he did what anybody who struck the
motherlode would do promised to build a
school and shopping mall
but first through a neighborhood party
multiple drug raids in the hills of
myanmar revealed a complex and
burgeoning synthetic drug market that's
speculated to be fueling global demand
for opioids like methamphetamine
and fentanyl the seizures were the
largest finds in southeast asian history
and represent a transition away from
china which had previously been
supplying many of the chemicals for
synthetics
but cracked down under worldwide
pressure
in kenya the score is one for the fig
tree
zero for developers a four-story tree in
the country's capital of nairobi was set
to be cut down to make way for an
expressway but environmentalists put up
a fight
and they won not only will the tree be
preserved in its spot but it's now been
elevated to legend status
gaining notoriety both as an
environmental symbol and as a call to
action to protect even more green space
in a city that's constantly seeing parks
and nature eliminated
in grimmer news the mayor of seoul the
capital of south korea
was found dead in a park this summer he
was a potential presidential candidate
and the second most powerful person in
the country
so the passing sent unrest through the
nation several days before his death a
former secretary
accused him of sexual harassment
especially shocking since he was a
champion of women's rights in a
male-dominated country
so his death is being treated as a
suicide
a less grim story comes from another
mayor on the other side of the world in
bogota colombia
who recently became the first openly
lesbian mayor ever for the capital city
in january
this was a historic moment for the
conservative catholic country
in latin america in general claudia
lopez married her partner in 2019
and is recognized for being a
progressive beacon in a region that's
slow to progress
lgbtq rights yachting in the iberian sea
was a little more raucous than usual
this fall
after a string of orca incidents were
reported in spain
in which killer whales were targeting
boat rudders and causing damage to more
than a dozen vessels
the increasingly aggressive interactions
initially puzzled researchers but they
now believe the trio of orcas
which accounted for almost two-thirds of
the two dozen reports
were previously injured by a boat and
perhaps reacting defensively to yachts
because of those traumatic incidents
another boating story brings us to
argentina where a determined sailor
finally docked on land after completing
an 85-day journey across the atlantic
ocean
the portuguese resident set sail in
mid-march after lockdown restrictions
kept him from traveling to see his
90-year-old father
he would not be deterred by the lack of
flights and decided to voyage by sea in
his 29-foot boat
accompanied by rice canned tuna and
fruit
uganda is home to 50 of the world's
mountain gorillas
so when one of the country's most famous
rafiki was killed by a poacher
the government took a harder stance than
it had previously
officials chose to jail the killer for
six years
this landmark ruling sends a message to
future poachers that animal killings
won't be tolerated
and is a win for wildlife groups which
have been calling for more restrictive
measures for many
years in terms of on-brand news for 2020
wildfires coming within one mile of
chernobyl in ukraine
has to be near the top of the list an
18-mile exclusion zone was set up after
the nuclear disaster there in the 80s
and this wildfire spread into that area
causing officials to worry that not only
would radioactive material be dispersed
into the air
but that it might threaten existing
structures and a disposal site
more than 300 firefighters were able to
control the burn
preventing this lesser-known story from
becoming a major
headline when a migrant rescue boat came
across a backpack floating in the
mediterranean sea
officials had assumed its owners had
perished in crossing from algeria to
italy
as is often the case with many found
personal objects floating in this part
of the world
but this time there was a happy ending
an ngo in italy was able to track down
the owners of the personal items who
were migrants that survived a shipwreck
and returned the contents to them
which included their inscribed wedding
rings
sudan is taking baby steps towards
democracy after three decades of
oppressive laws that were primarily
targeted towards women
of highest priority is banning female
genital mutilation
a typically religious practice that
affects almost 90 percent
of sudanese women the new transitional
government is also loosening wardrobe
restrictions for women
and saying okay to alcohol consumption
at least for non-muslims in the country
the 3 600 year old gilgamesh dream
tablet is being returned to its rightful
home in what is now iraq where it
originated
after a curious and illegal journey that
brought it to the museum of the bible in
washington dc
which was co-founded by none other than
tablet king and crafts retail giant
hobby lobby
the rare cuneiform tablet features one
of the oldest works of literature in the
world
the epic of gilgamesh and was purchased
by hobby lobby at
auction for 1.6 million dollars in 2014
this isn't the first time hobby lobby
has had problems with the providence of
its acquisitions
as it previously had to forfeit 5 500
artifacts and pay
a 3 million fine national identity cards
in afghanistan include
a person's name date of birth and now
both of their parents names
which sounds pretty normal but
previously just the father's name was
listed because using a women's in public
was traditionally frowned upon and even
considered an insult
it's a restriction that goes so far that
much of afghanistan does not list
females names on their gravestones
this step in updating id cards is seen
as a small victory for women's rights in
the overwhelmingly conservative
country when a herd of elephants at
poland's warsaw zoo became
sad after losing their matriarch which
lead a given hurt
veterinarians turned to colorado's
favorite stress reliever
medical marijuana the three african
elephants
are given doses of liquid cannabis
through their trunks and researchers
will study hormone levels in their blood
over the next two years to monitor how
it affects their stress a small town of
7 000 people in canada
gave itself a new identity when they
voted this year to change the city's
name from asbestos to valdezos or
valley of the springs the town got its
name for being home to the largest
asbestos mine in the world
but since the mineral has been linked to
causing cancer and the mind has shot
residents voted to disassociate from the
toxic
substance but it wasn't without a fight
more veteran members of the community
were opposed to the name change as they
felt it was unnecessary
because in french which is spoken there
the word for asbestos
is amiant tensions are simmering in a
united nations-backed buffer zone
between morocco and mauritania
which could bring a 29-year truce to a
boiling point
the western sahara contested zone has
long been controlled by morocco
under a ceasefire agreement with the
polisario front a pro-independence
movement
but now the front has blocked
transportation between the two countries
and morocco has launched a military
operation in response
on the same latitude but a few time
zones over saudi arabia wants to
maintain its claim as the world's top
energy exporter
but now with hydrogen blue hydrogen
is a carbon dioxide byproduct of
reforming natural gas
and saudi arabia sent its first cargo
shipment of it to japan this year
all in an effort to profit off the
world's transition to greener fuels
part of this goal also includes plans to
build a 5 billion
hydrogen-based ammonia plant powered by
renewable energy
on the red sea uzbekistan's language can
be written in three ways
arabic cyrillic and latin but it's the
latter that will soon be the norm
thanks to a decree by the country's
president which called for a faster
transition away from cyrillic
though uzbek was originally written in
arabic russian influence during the
early 20th century changed it to
cyrillic
and now to distance itself from russia
uzbekistan wants to move towards latin
script consisting of 29 letters and one
apostrophe
to help develop a stronger more unique
national
identity peruvians are hoping that the
third time's a charm
after three presidents reigned in just
one week
francisco sagasti will now lead the
country following a congress-led ousting
of one president
and a five-day term-turned-resignation
by the second
sagasti is seen as a consensus builder
so citizens are hopeful
but the tumultuous leadership changes
over the past several years
leave a lot of uncertainty and frankly
apathy
at this point if there's a baby boom
this spring
a shortage of condom manufacturing in
march may be
the culprit a malaysian company
carrick's bhd
makes one in every five condoms globally
and when the pandemic hit this year
facilities were forced to shut down
resulting in at least 100 million fewer
condoms worldwide
it ramped back up quickly but the
effects of a shortage like this
could be at least nine months away
it's been a year for africa's richest
woman
isabel dos santos she's the eldest
daughter of angola's former long-time
leader jose eduardo dos santos and in
january was charged with embezzlement
and laundering more than one billion
dollars from her native country
then in october her husband died in
reportedly
a diving accident off the coast of dubai
he was an avid art collector and also
tied up in the scandal she faced
meaning it's a tragic tale with lots of
plot twists that doesn't seem to have a
final
chapter yet another story about one
billion dollars
revolves around the united kingdom's
investment in mozambique
this year a deal was inked to send uk
taxpayer-funded financial support to
develop and export the african country's
gas reserves
one of the largest financing projects on
the continent ever according to some
reports
but citizens and environmental groups
are shouting hypocrite as the uk
continues to claim it's a global leader
in the fight against climate change
speaking of oil in africa a floating
storage and offloading facility moored
off the coast of yemen
continues to deteriorate and threatens
to spill 1.1
million barrels of crude oil into the
red sea which would be
four times the amount of the exxon
valdez spill
the war in yemen has prevented the
united nations from doing anything to
prevent a potential leak
but recently houthi rebels which control
the area where the vessel is stuck
and the oil company that owns it gave
permission for world leaders to move
ahead with rehabilitation
plans the african country of ghana
may be a respite for black americans
seeking refuge from the united states is
ongoing racial injustice
and canadian officials are actually
recruiting members of the african
diaspora
the government set up a handful of
enticements for transplants
including land yields expatriate guides
and quicker paths to citizenship
and all of this comes on the heels of a
45 increase in visitor numbers
from the united states last year math
science and reading
are of course required subjects for
children in school
and now in one country downward dog is
two in march nepal became the first
nation
in the world to incorporate yoga into
its mandatory curriculum
students in the himalayan country won't
just practice the poses
but they'll learn about the history of
yogurt thought and ayurvedic medicine
children or the idea of them at least
are making headlines in venezuela
where controversial twitter happy
president nicolas maduro
asked for every woman in the country to
have six children
the plea was met with immediate backlash
because the country is in a
deep economic recession and is unable to
provide essential services like food and
health care for the millions of
residents it already has
he apparently views more children as
part of the solution
though he offered little in the way of
specifics as to how
ever heard of volsko's chameleon no well
that's okay
almost nobody has since the elusive
reptile hadn't been seen in almost 100
years
and was actually placed on the
extinction list but
this year a team of researchers spotted
it on the northwest
tip of madagascar there the reptile is
only thought to live during the rainy
season
making it a mayfly of vertebrae this of
course
makes it even more vulnerable to the
deforestation that continues to threaten
their sheer
existence but its rediscovery gives
scientists hope for other species which
were also thought to be extinct
the unearthing of four 8 000 year old
skeletons in cameroon
is a groundbreaking find that's
providing new information about our
current
human species the dna from these
skeletons
offers the first genetic material from
west african humans
painting a better picture of how ancient
people split into four genetic groups
both physically and geographically of
the four populations
it's been the west african genes that
have remained elusive to researchers
until now political unrest looms over
the ivory coast as president alessan
otara won controversially a third term
in
november when his planned successor
suddenly died this summer
uttara reneged on his pledge to leave
office and even though he received 94
of the votes many including the
opposition saw the process as unfair
it's indicative of a wider trend in
african politics which has seen
third term bids and constitutional
amendments increasing
in recent years more than 40 percent of
north korean men smoke
but a new law that bans puffing down in
public places
might smolder that statistic citing
health reasons
tobacco is now prohibited in specific
venues such as political and ideological
education centers
theaters cinemas and medical and public
health facilities
one person who might struggle with this
new law leader kim jong-un
who is a chain smoker and frequently
photographed with a cigarette in hand
but the country is moving forward with
the prohibition despite being unable to
convince its supreme leader
to kick the habit another big find was
recently made by scientists this time in
the great barrier reef of the coast of
australia
where a pinnacle of coral one third of a
mile long was discovered by researchers
while you might think that the world
famous natural wonder would be
thoroughly mapped out
this was actually the first major new
element of the reef to be discovered
in over 120 years of course the reef
is shrinking by the year due to the
effects of climate change and coral
bleaching
so even the discovery of this
comparatively small section
is great news niger is one of the
world's poorest countries but its
location also makes it a key regional
recipient of western aid funding the
fight against islamic terrorism
that's why an audit of its defense
spending that revealed a loss of 137
million dollars over eight years
raised more than eyebrows apparently the
country was overcharged in several
instances
sometimes by nearly 20 million dollars
for important military equipment
and western countries that grant niger
money are questioning their decisions
and potentially future giving you don't
have to worry about the spread of
airborne
viruses in sri lanka's newest museum
because it's
underwater created by naval officers off
the southern tip of the island nation
the country's first ever below water
museum is a collection of artifacts and
sculptures installed 50 feet beneath the
surface
the attraction is not only intended to
draw tourists but it should lure fish
and spur coral growth too one of burkina
faso's largest gold mines was shut down
for almost a year after
39 employees were killed in an attack on
their convoy
since then the canadian-owned bungu mine
has restarted with titan security
measures and improved infrastructure
during the year hiatus the mine's owners
actually changed from one canadian
company to another for 735 million
dollars
which is notable because even though
agriculture still accounts for 80
percent of the country's economy
gold exports driven by foreign
investments continue to develop
alternate economic sectors and on the
subject of west african unrest
a military coup in mali ousted the
country's president and prime minister
in august
following eight years of disrupted
elections government corruptions
and islamic insurgency military colonels
remain in power today
this further instability could send
ripple effects across the region because
of mali's strategic location for western
countries
such as france and the united states
which have actively tried to prevent
increased tensions
in the area file this story under
stranger than fiction because
well it's about non-fiction some 200
books
including first editions by galileo and
sir isaac newton
were found buried underneath a rural
romanian cottage
after a three-year search that spanned
45 addresses in three
countries the 3.35 million dollars worth
of books
were stolen during a heist from a london
warehouse in 2017.
looking to get away from it all for a
cool 20 million dollars
you can buy a 50 000 acre island off the
coast of chile
acquiring private islands is nothing new
but this one is making headlines because
environmentalists and the indigenous
population are not happy that this
biodiversity hotspot has a price tag
at all even though the island has been
in private hands for a century
they're worried that new ownership could
jeopardize its future conservation
and sets a dangerous precedent in an
effort to bolster its economy
malawi became the fifth african country
to decriminalize medical marijuana
almost 80 percent of the country's
population is employed in agriculture
and it used to be a major producer of
tobacco but
as global demand for tobacco declines
it's looking for alternate revenue
streams
enter malawi gold an already popular
strain of recreational cannabis
the country's dry climate is actually
conducive to growing marijuana
and as the herb's popularity increases
around the world
malawians plan to jump on the ganja
train
kazakhstan is known for a few things its
oil and gas
economy its proximity to russia and
mongolia and just generally for being a
stan
but in western culture is perhaps most
famous for one of its fictional natives
borat sagiev played by actor sasha baron
cohen the satirical character borat
pokes fun at kazakhstan with the
catchphrase very nice
but officials there realize those words
have standing power and recently
officially adopted them as their
official
tourism slogan the african ancel molrat
native to zambia is near blind burrows
underground
and this year scientists discovered it
can sense magnetic fields with its eyes
though the animal's eyes are barely
functional discerning between just light
and dark
this new discovery gives more clues as
to how the creature travels and lives in
an underground network
up to 1.7 miles or 2.7 kilometers long
and of course it may help humans in our
own scientific advances
as we learn more about nature and as we
often do
try to mimic it government officials in
guatemala passed a 12.2 billion dollar
budget that raised stipends for
representatives meals
while cutting funding for human rights
agencies healthcare and education
triggering residents to protest in the
streets and set the congressional
building
on fire their anger at the misplaced
spending comes on the heels of not only
the pandemic
but two destructive hurricanes that tore
through the country this fall
it turns out tragedy after tragedy is
when people need help
the most in july ecuador reported that
more than 300 chinese fishing vessels
were encroaching on its exclusive
fishing zones near the galapagos
with the illegal fishing fleets going as
far as to turn off their tracking
devices to remain undetected
so the south american country joined
coastal neighbors chile peru and
colombia to file a joint statement
or rather a light threat about
protecting their waters from the
increasing creep of foreign fishing
and ultimately china's expanding
presence
overseas some new research into the life
of the netherlands most famous artists
vincent van gogh reveals that he didn't
suffer from schizophrenia or syphilis
as some have theorized but rather that
the delirium leading up to his death
may be attributed to alcohol withdrawal
the artist was institutionalized twice
once after cutting off his ear and
reported hallucinations both times
researchers now believe these symptoms
were due to his lack of wine and
absinthe which he consumed in great
amounts during the most prolific
and final years of his life in
somber news syria topped an unenviable
list in 2019
being named the deadliest place in the
world for humanitarian workers
the report on the subject released this
year details that the number of people
killed helping the war-torn country rose
sharply last year
with the majority of deaths stemming
from aerial strikes
officials say the grim statistic will
make it harder to recruit aid workers to
a place
where they're needed the most one rodent
that's turning its species reputation
around
is magawa a land mine sniffing rat in
cambodia
the five-year-old african pouched rat
has discovered 39 landmines
28 pieces of unexploded ordnance and
helped clear more than 1.5 million
square feet of land over the past four
years
rightfully earning itself the gold medal
from the people's dispensary for sick
animals
that unsurprisingly makes it the first
rat to receive an award that is usually
reserved for humans
after the tragic port explosion in
beirut
senegal moved quickly to avoid a similar
catastrophe and removed 3050 tons of
ammonium nitrate from its port
the substance was transported to mali
where it was used to make bombs for
mining operations
ammonium nitrate is commonly found in
fertilizers and explosives
so ports around the world which
temporarily house the volatile compound
such as senegal's dakar
made sure they weren't in the same
vulnerable situation as beirut
where the substance led to the
accidental explosion that killed 190
people
south african extrative economies
continue to make headlines such as chad
which recently asked unesco to postpone
the process for designating lake chad
as a world heritage site why
because chad wants to explore oil and
gas development in the lake area
which directly opposes unesco's
conservation goals for
world heritage sites it also came as a
surprise to cameroon
niger and nigeria which cooperated on
the two-year application process for the
multinational lake to gain this
distinctive designation
more fish theft brings us to the coast
of somalia which stretches 2000 miles or
3200 kilometers and is the longest
coastline in africa
that expanse makes it harder for the
country to police its waters
where poachers like a 192 vessel fleet
from iran
are illegally fishing in the country's
exclusive economic zone
the size of the iranian operation
discovered this year
is a blow to somalia where one in three
residents face hunger and it
demonstrates the rising tensions over
the planet's
limited natural resources one resource
being exported out of africa that
benefits from increased demand
is a zimbabwean film that became the
country's first feature to make it
to netflix the movie cook-off is about a
woman who enters a tv cooking show
and it was made for just eight thousand
dollars an impressive feat given that it
was produced in 2017
just before the country's economy
collapsed this acquisition by the
streaming giant gives more credibility
to zimbabwe's film industry
and means that the production crew and
actors may finally
get paid a small band of chimpanzees in
guinea that are known for their
remarkable use of tools
were thought to be near extinction until
the tribe's last fertile female gave
birth to a beacon
of hope another female deforestation and
isolation led to the tribe's demise
and this group is of particular interest
to researchers because they mimic humans
use of tools
but this bundle of joy has also created
momentum for the country's residents to
increase
protections and forestation to ensure
there is a future
for the chimpanzees one of the world's
most wanted fugitives was found this
year in a small apartment on the
outskirts of paris
felician kabuga was arrested for his
role in the rwandan genocide
which killed 800 000 members of the
tutsi ethnic minority among others
in 1994. kabuka will be tried in a u.n
tribunal court next year
and this capture renews efforts to find
others on the run
who played significant roles in the
country's darkest
days france and bennen also made news in
with the former's government
fast-tracking a bill aimed at returning
looted objects to the sub-saharan
country within a year
the move is part of a multi-year
restitution effort between european
countries and their former colonies
and this law specifically returns 26
royal artifacts that were stolen from
the oboemi palace during the 19th
century
these cultural repatriation efforts are
ongoing signaling an african drive to
reclaim its cultural identity
after centuries of european pillaging
efforts to protect sea turtles in
tunisia are working
says new scientific research that shows
nests on kuriat island have increased
from 11
to more than 40 since 1997. turtles are
a keystone species
meaning their disappearance would
disproportionately damage ecosystems
and their increased presence in this
area despite threats from people climate
and pollution
is good news for the reptiles and the
workers striving to save them
two chinese bidders with the pseudonym
super duper and hitman
bought a belgian racing pigeon for a
record price of
1.9 million dollars belgium is the
world's leading racing pigeon breeding
country
and thanks to a booming economy the
chinese upper class have
a lot of money to spend even compared to
a decade ago
so why not invest in something like a
pigeon the bird will likely be bred with
another genetically superior pigeon to
create a super bird that will dominate
in racing circles
and betting on those is just one area
where the chinese are spending
significant amounts of their uen
11 months in argentina sounds nice but
for bolivian president evo morales
it was more of an exile he re-entered
bolivia this november after a 2019
campaign for a fourth presidential term
became marred by fraud allegations
leading him to flee the country a
caretaker government has managed affairs
since then
but when morales former economic
minister recently assumed leadership
it paved the way for morales to return
though it's unclear what role he'll play
in the country's new
reality if it all sounds turbulent it is
latin american countries continue to
struggle with government instability
and this is just one more on the list
the financial situation in cuba worsened
this year
when the united states placed increased
restrictions on the country
forcing the closure of 400 western union
offices and potentially cutting off a
stream of remittances from abroad
the united states claims the move came
in response to the cuban government
purportedly siphoning a cut of the
incoming money
but officials there say the move was
politically motivated
cuban-american relations have become
more tenuous under trump
but the new biden administration is
expected to reinstate diplomatic
relations
especially since cuban refugee alejandro
mayarcas has been nominated to lead the
department of homeland security
hopping one island over haiti's local
president of fifa
the governing body for soccer has been
shut out and not
in the winning way haitian football
president yves joomba was issued a
lifetime ban from all football-related
activities
after he was found guilty of sexually
harassing and abusing female players
including minors he was also fined
roughly 1.1
million dollars many are lauding the
punishment
saying abuse should be rooted out of any
industry at any
level south sudan is the world's
youngest country
formed in 2011. since then it's
experienced
almost a decade of civil war but earlier
this year
feuding parties finally signed a unity
agreement
millions of people continue to flee the
country and suffer from extreme hunger
but the establishment of a ruling party
offers one step in the right direction
toward stability president pierre in
currenziza of burundi
died suddenly of a heart attack at the
age of 55.
he leaves behind a legacy as an
autocratic ruler known for committing a
variety of human rights abuses
and his death in june came just weeks
after the country had already elected a
successor
which only happened because encurn ziza
did not seek re-election
his death will have impacts on regional
and global relations
potentially allowing for increased unity
under new leadership
despite the pandemic the dominican
republic has hosted more than two dozen
feature film and tv production shoots
this year
which poured 80 million dollars into the
local economy smashing a previous annual
record of 30 million dollars in 2017.
producers track their local expenditures
because part of the country's
international incentive for filming
there is a 25
rebate through a transferable tax credit
that's attractive to american filmmakers
like m night shyamalan who took
advantage of it this year
because they can spend 25 percent of
wages in the dominican republic and
maintain
tax incentive status in the united
states
a deer stealing their rifle isn't
something that hunters would think
they'd have to worry about when out
stalking
but that's what happened to one in the
czech republic when his dog startled the
deer
which ran toward him and looped his
rifle with an antler
the deer was seen a mile away with the
gun still in tow
reportedly it wasn't loaded but had it
been a deer claiming self-defense
might have worked in this case also
filed under bizarre sightings is a tiny
child floating on an inflatable unicorn
in the mediterranean sea the
three-year-old girl was swept into the
water while playing on a beach in greece
but rescued shortly after by a passing
fairy boat she was delivered back to her
family safely
and yes the unicorn made it too when
brazilian maya gibberish surfed a 73.5
foot or 22.4 meter wave of the coast of
portugal in february
she didn't just ride the biggest wave
ever for a woman it was the largest wave
surfed by
anyone period during the 2019-2020
season
she is the first woman in professional
surfing to top all men in terms of wave
size in a season
but with another female surfer earning
spot number two on the big wave list
this year it's clear she may not hold
the title for long
the title for the highest smoking rate
in the world goes to jordan
where a shocking 80 percent of the male
population says they use smoke or use
nicotine products daily
this was a status previously held by
indonesia and bucked the global trend of
declining tobacco use
multinational tobacco companies are
still allowed to hold a large amount of
influence in jordan
from funding school programs to being
featured on the prime minister's social
media
and this widespread interference is
likely what's increasing
use rapper cardi b may have overstepped
her political boundaries when she posted
an advertisement supporting armenia
to her 76 million instagram followers
like all wars the conflict between
azerbaijan and armenia has been a tragic
one
that ended with armenia's defeat and a
pact between the two countries
over the disputed territory of
nagorno-karabash which will remain
with azerbaijan but cardi b was only
trying to help a real estate agent
friend when she made the post
and has since apologized amid the
backlash
unstaffed grocery stores accessed by
logging in with bank id
the national identification app operated
by sweden's banks
seems like something only sweden could
pull off in remote areas
which is why they're probably the ones
doing it amid a drastic decline in food
markets across the country
mostly in rural areas the company lives
has installed almost
20 small container stores that are fully
stocked with meat
vegetables dairy and desserts customers
simply swipe an app to enter and pay for
groceries
no store clerk needed israeli flights
traveling to and from the united arab
emirates can now cross through saudi
arabian airspace
marking the first time that commercial
jets on this route can pass over the
kingdom's territory
the announcement cuts travel time
between the two countries in half to
three and a half
hours and signals normalizing relations
both diplomatically
and economically according to reports
the decision to open the airspace
came at the request of the uae it became
the third arab country to acknowledge
relations with israel behind egypt and
jordan
and the development signals some
progress in an otherwise unstable region
though saudi arabia was quick to note
that opening airspace didn't change the
country's stance on the israel-palestine
issue
despite having previously faced murder
charges juan carlos bonilla valadares
aka the tiger was still named police
chief in 2012 in honduras
so it may not come as a surprise that he
didn't uphold the tenets of the job
and is now charged with conspiring to
smuggle cocaine into the united states
but the plot thickens he wasn't
smuggling cocaine for just
anyone but doing the dirty work for the
honduran president and his brother
the latter of which was convicted for
drug trafficking in new york
last year in hungary a scientist
accidentally created a new fish hybrid
in a lab
dubbed the sturtlefish the combination
of russian sturgeon whose eggs make
premium caviar and american paddlefish
a filter feeder found in less than half
of the united states
is an unlikely one that would probably
never have occurred without human
intervention
based on geography alone and while
there's no real practical purpose to the
awkward looking creature
it does demonstrate that species
genetics are sometimes more similar than
previously
thought also in the neighborhood is the
proposed baltic black sea waterway
a 12 040 mile 2000 kilometer inland
shipping route that would cut through
poland
ukraine and some of the most
ecologically rich parts of belarus
oh and it would involve dredging up land
inside the chernobyl exclusion zone
which could potentially expose millions
of people to latent nuclear waste
proponents say it would spur an economic
boon for the region
while opponents argue it will destroy
the quote amazon of europe
it may end up happening piecemeal with
ukraine and belarus committing
and already starting in some cases to
dredging up parts of their tributary
rivers tajikistan is one of the poorest
countries in east
asia and many residents cross into
russia for higher paying jobs
and higher education the
russian-speaking population in this
country has dwindled tenfold in four
decades
but there's new interest in teaching
children their neighbor's language
marks by officials announcement that
they would build five more
russian-speaking schools
with a capacity for 1200 students in
each in addition to the 10 that have
been constructed in just the past
two years a musician in austria is
pulling
a different sort of string that of
wolfgang amadeus mozart's 250 year old
violin
the musician took a leap when he asked
the foundation that owns the violin if
he could borrow it to play and record
the violin concertos
on the exact instrument mozart composed
them on between 1773
and 1775. the answer was yes and he
performed them in october
to small live audiences a group of
united nations officials signed a letter
to four countries
protesting the development of a massive
mine in papua new guinea
citing grave concerns both for the
environment and human rights
if built the mine would be the largest
in the nation's history
and potentially produce 1.5 billion
dollars of gold
copper and silver annually for 30 years
that money would mostly go to chinese
investors in the australian registered
mining company
and the real costs would come in the
form of catastrophic economic disaster
on the sepec river
where it would be located more than 43
million tweets amplifying positive news
coverage of serbian president alexander
vucic were linked to his serbian
progressive party
and twitter subsequently blocked 8 500
accounts for attempts to undermine
public conversation
the tweets were making his governing
look better than it actually was
and this isn't just happening in serbia
the tech company blocked some additional
13 000 accounts in countries like egypt
honduras and saudi arabia for doing the
same
thing serbia is the 98th largest country
in the world
meaning we're halfway to 195. therefore
that's where we'll end part one and part
two will be going up
december 31st while you wait for that
though i have something else
new and rather exciting for you to watch
tomorrow on nebula
we release the first episode of sam from
wendover presents a very good trivia
show presented by sam from wendover
you see we were going to film something
for our last nebula original of the year
on location like we normally do
but then you know everything got in the
way can't break our c
word rule now therefore we decided to do
something completely different
a trivia show filmed remotely with three
fantastic contestants
brian from real engineering dave from
city beautiful and jordan herrera
they competed in seven games some of
which were pretty normal and others of
which were pretty
out there this was all hosted by me and
i even go on camera so get mentally
prepared for that
of course the only place to watch this
is on nebula as their business model
makes
bigger projects like this financially
possible and there's quite literally
never been
a better time to sign up that's because
our sponsor curiositystream is having
its biggest ever sale
41 off meaning it works out to less than
one
dollar a month and by signing up at
curiositystream.comwendover
any subscription is bundled with a
nebulous subscription for the exact
same price that's two whole streaming
sites with thousands of top quality
documentaries and non-fiction shows from
bigger names in the case of curiosity
stream
and tons of bigger budget projects from
your favorite educationalist creators in
the case of nebula
for less than the cost of a bus fare per
month
while you wait for our original to come
out you could for example watch
something quite similar to this video
it's where curiosity stream rounds up
the top science stories of 2020 in an
hour-long special
which is quite good this sale will end
very soon so make sure to sign up at
curiositystream.comwendover and you'll
be supporting this
and countless other independent channels
while you're at it